Україна мала попрощатися з виборчою системою часів Януковича вже давно -
ще чотири роки тому це обіцяв президент Петро Порошенко.
Власне, це прописано в Коаліційній угоді нинішнього парламенту.
Проте попри зміну влади виборчої реформи досі не відбулося.
Які зміни конче потрібні українському виборчому законодавству?
В Україні діє змішана виборча система, за якою половина депутатів
обирається з мажоритарних округів,
решта - за пропорційною системою із закритими партійними списками.
Основною проблемою закритих списків є купівля "прохідних місць",
коли виборці не знають, за кого голосують.
Фактично вибори перетворилися на змагання "грошових мішків",
де хто більше платить, той потрапляє у партійний список, зазначають експерти.
Відтак вагомим фактором на перегонах стають гроші,
а не ідеї чи репутація кандидата або партії.
Тим часом серед недоліків мажоритарної системи називають те,
що перемагає кандидат, який отримує більшість голосів,
навіть якщо це лише 20%.
Відповідно решта 80% голосів ігноруються.
Крім того, депутати-мажоритарники
часто потрапляють у парламент через підкуп виборців.
Водночас, мажоритарники-бізнесмени
нерідко стають виконавцями замовлень влади,
адже за "потрібні" голосування отримують гарантії недоторканності свого бізнесу.
Оптимальною для України, на думку експертів,
є пропорційна система з відкритими списками.
Щоб потрапити до парламенту, кандидатам треба буде
реально працювати на округах.
Тоді як торгівля місцями у виборчих списках стане невигідною,
адже ніхто не зможе гарантувати результат.
Іще одне важливе нововведення,
на якому наполягають експерти, -
посилення відповідальності за порушення на виборах.
Задля цього у громадянській мережі "Опора"
вже напрацювали відповідний законопроект.
Якщо його схвалять, то, приміром, за незаконне вкидання бюлетеня
та продаж голосу можна буде потрапити за ґрати на два роки,
а за підкуп виборця - на шість. Крім того,
вперше може бути запроваджена відповідальність за підкуп кандидатів.
Ідеться про так званих "технічних кандидатів"
чи "кандидатів-двійників", яких фінансують
впливові учасники виборів.
Виборча реформа неможлива без зміни членів
Центральної виборчої комісії,
термін повноважень більшості з яких сплив
ще кілька років тому, наголошують оглядачі.
І українські експерти, і міжнародні партнери
наполягають на оновленні складу ЦВК.
Адже дієздатний Центрвиборчком і політичний баланс його членів
дуже важливі для чесності подальших виборів.
Утім, навіть змінити склад Центрвиборчкому
нинішня влада поки так і не спромоглася.
Президент не міг визначитися із кандидатами більше трьох років
на розгляд парламенту кандидатури
14 нових членів ЦВК лише кілька місяців тому.
Причому більшість з них - кандидати від провладних фракцій
"Блок Петра Порошенка" та "Народний фронт",
що загрожує незалежності цього органу.
Питання оновлення складу ЦВК парламент може розглянути 17 травня.